اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
اسرائيل تساعده في الضفه الغربيه وتتاهب
على حدود غزه ومصر تحذر الفصائل من غارات
جديده
غارات عنيفه للجيش السوداني وسط الخرطوم
وسما عدوي انفجارات واشتباكات شرق ام
درمان
انصاره مثول عمران خان
تتاهب
قبيل الاجتماع التركي السوري في موسكو
انقره تكشف عن اتفاق لانشاء مركز تدزيق
امني في سوريا
صباح الخير لا تزالوا مشاهدينا الاراضي
الفلسطينيه تشهد مزيدا من التصعيد بعد
الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه والتي
قتلت 13 فلسطينيين بينهم ثلاثه من قاده
حركه الجهاد ففي الضفه الغربيه قتل شابان
فلسطينيان برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
مصادر طبيه فلسطينيه بان الشابين
اي بلده قباطيه في مدينه جنين احدهما من
البلده والاخر من مخيم جنين وذكرت وسائل
اعلام محليه ان اشتباكات عنيفه دارت بين
فلسطينيين وجنود اسرائيليين في قباطيه في
الوقت نفسه مشاهدينا اقتحمت قوات
اسرائيليه مخيم عقبه جبر في اريحا وطوباس
وشنت حمله اعتقالات واسعه كما اندلعت
اشتباكات مسلحه بين نشطاء وقوات اسرائيليه
في مخيم طولكرم شمال الضفه الغربيه وايضا
اعتقل الجيش الاسرائيلي تسعه عشر
فلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
المحتله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنى من رام الله مراسل العربيه خالد
القاسم اهلا بك معنا خالد ما اخر التطورات
حول ما جرى اليوم من حمله اعتقالات وتصعيد
اسرائيلي في مختلف مناطق الضفه الغربيه
حسب بدايه الحديث اخر التطورات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه ان عدد المعتقلين بحسب بعض
المؤسسات الخاصه ارتفع الى ثمانيه وعشرين
معتقلا اعتقلهم الجيش الاسرائيلي في
قباطيه
قتل فلسطينيان برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
واصيبه ثلاثه اخرون اضافه الى عدد من
المعتقلين الذين اعتقلتهم القوات
الاسرائيليه حيث افاد شهود عيان بان قوه
اسرائيليه خاصه
توغلت الى بلده قباطيه عبر ثلاجه على
شاحنه تم اكتشاف امرها واجرت هناك
اشتباكات مسلحه بين هذه القوات الخاصه
وبين مسلحين فلسطينيين سرعان ما دفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي بتعزيزات كبيره الى المنطقه
بالمناسبه فاطمه انا لا اسمع
صوتك
دفع الجيش الاسرائيلي بتعزيزات الى
المنطقه
دارت خلالها اشتباكات شهود العيان افادوا
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي اطلق النار على
مركبه فلسطينيه فيها شاباني فلسطينيين تم
تصفيته مع
في المكان ثم انسحبت القوات الاسرائيليه
من المنطقه ايضا هناك في بلده دير ديبوان
اصيب ثلاثه فلسطينيين اثنان منهم اصيب
بالرصاص الذي اطلقه مستوطنون حاولوا
الوصول الى منطقه رعي الاغنام والثالث
اصيب بكسر في الركبه قبل انسحاب الجيش
الاسرائيلي والقوات الخاصه من المكان
جزيلا لك من رام الله مراسل العربيه خالد
القاسم
اسرائيل مشاهدينا التي تترقب رد الفصائل
تواصل تاهبها في جميع الجبهات مؤكده انها
مستعده لجميع السيناريوهات بموازات ذلك
حضرت مصر الفصائل من عمليات اغتيال
اسرائيليه جديده وارسلت رساله للجانب
الاسرائيلي تحذر فيه من استهداف قاده
اخرين من حماس والجهاد وذلك بحسب ما نقلت
مصادر العربيه المصادر اشارت ايضا الى ان
الفصائل غيرت اماكن تواجد قادتها
العسكريين ونقلتهم الى اماكن امنه وقررت
الفصائل بحسب مصادر العربيه قررت تاخير
الرد لحين وضع خطط امنيه احترازيه ومراجعه
التحركات وتامين القاده في ضوء هذه
الاجراءات الامنيه الجديده لفتت المصادر
الى ان الاتصالات بين الوسطاء وقاده
الفصائل اصبحت صعبه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من حدود قطاع غزه تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه لانا كالغاصي اهلا بك معنا لانا
اذا بدايه كيف استفاقت غزه بعد اغتيالات
الامس
اهلا بك فاطمه وبجميع المشاهدين فعليا نعم
لقد استفقت غزه على هدوء حذر وهدوء تام
بعد ان قامت القوات الاسرائيليه باغتيال
ثلاثه من قاده الجهاد الاسلامي وفعليا
الان هناك هدوء حذر حسب ما يتم وصفه فعليا
ايضا يعني
طبيعه الطبيعه اليوميه او العمل ايضا
والوظائف سواء في الوزارات المحليه في
قطاع غزه او اي وظائف اخرى تم فعليا
توقيفها اي نحن نتكلم عن الحياه اليوميه
في قطاع غزه لقد توقفت بشكل كلي ايضا
الجهات التعليميه والجهاز التعليمي
والمدارس لقد اغلقت ابوابها في قطاع غزه
ولكن هناك طائرات استطلاع مكثفه كانت
فعليا تطير فوق سماء قط
لتراقب التحركات الجهاد الاسلامي او حماس
او الفصائل الفلسطينيه المختلفه في قطاع
غزه هذه هو الحال فعليا في قطاع هناك حاله
من
هدوء حذر كما ذكرتي ولكن ايضا هناك طائرات
استطلاع وهناك تاهب اسرائيلي كذلك على
الحدود ما نوع التاهب ما الاجراءات التي
تتخذها او يتخذها الجيش الاسرائيلي للتاهب
والاستعداد لاي هجمات من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه
صحيح هناك حاله من التاهب والجاهزيه
الكبيره حسب ما تصفها القوات الامنيه كان
هناك ايضا جلسه للكابينه مساء امس يعني
دراسه الاوضاع الامنيه وكيفيه ربما سوف
يكون الرد من قبل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه نحن الان
نقف بالقرب بالقرب من القبه الحديديه
القوات والعناصر الاسرائيليه قبل قليل
منعتنا من تصوير القبه الحديديه ولكن نحن
قريبين بشكل كبير الى هذه القبه هناك
انتشار للقبه الحديديه وايضا حاله تاهب
قامت ايضا الشرطه الاسرائيليه باواء
القوات الامنيه باستدعاء الجنود الاحتياط
ايضا الان يقوم فعليا المصور
يحاول رصد فعليا القبه الحديديه التي هي
موجوده بالقرب من الان هناك حاله تاهب
كبيره ايضا القوات الاسرائيليه قد قالت
ومنع
المدارس من فتح ابوابها هنا في المستوطنات
القريبه من قطاع غزه هناك حاله من التوتر
والتاهب ولكن في الخطاب الاسرائيلي الان
هناك الحديث عن او سؤال كبير فعليا هل سوف
تقوم حركه حماس بالمشاركه في هذا الرد
جنبا للجهاد الاسلامي وهذا هو السؤال
البارز حاليا في الخطاب الاسرائيلي شكرا
جزيلا لك من حدود قطاع غزه مراسله العربيه
لنا كالغاصي
هذا ودع البيت الابيض الى احتواء التصعيد
في غزه مدافعا في الوقت ذاته عن ما سماه
حق اسرائيل بالدفاع عن نفسها من الهجمات
الصاروخيه العشوائيه التي تشنها جماعات
ارهابيه على حد تعبيره واكد متحدث باسم
البيت الابيض مشاهدينا اكد التزام
الولايات المتحده الراسخ تجاه اسرائيل في
حقها بحمايه نفسها وجاء الموقف الامريكي
بعد اطلاق الجيش الاسرائيلي حمله ضد حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي
ينضم الينا من غزه الصحفي احمد حرب اهلا
بك معنا احمد اذا يعني انباء تتحدث عن
قاده فصائل التي توعدت بالرد على الغارات
الاسرائيليه يتحركون ويعيدون تموضع انفسهم
وهناك ايضا قطع او قله في استخدام الهواتف
النقاله كيف تفهم هذه التحركات من قاده
الفصائل الفلسطينيه يعني
التحركات والتغييرات تفهم بان التصعيد
الاسرائيلي مازال قائما في قطاع غزه ما
زالت الردود
على قبل قليل كان هناك
تصريح للمتحدث باسم حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
الرد المناسب على اسرائيل هو يخضع لخطط
الفصائل والمقاومه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي
هذا يضع
القطاع واسرائيل على المحك فيما يتعلق
من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه على عمليه
الاغتيال حتى هذه اللحظه الضبابيه والترقب
والانتظار هما سيداء الموقع في قطاع غزه
خاصه ان هناك تهديدات فلسطينيه من قبل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بالرد على عمليه
الاغتيال ولكن
حتى ومنذ فجر امس عقب عمليه الاغتيال وحتى
اليوم يعني لا يوجد اي رد من قبل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه طيب اذا جانب التهديدات بالرد
احمد هناك ايضا تحذيرات مصريه من عمليات
اغتيالات جديده كذلك كيف تتناول الفصائل
هذه التحذيرات من مصر
يعني هذه التحذيرات هي قائمه والفصائل
تاخذ الحيطه والحذر فيها هكذا
التحركات يعني خفيفه جدا وليست موجوده ولا
تذكر من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه وعناصرها
وقادتها وبالتالي يعني هذه التحذيرات تدخل
يعني من قبل مصر تكون في اطار ان يجب يعني
احتواء الموقف ومنع انزلاق الامور الاخر
جميع الاطراف الدوليه والاطراف الفاعله في
تهدئه الاوضاع في القطاع ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه
تهدئه في القطاع خاصه وان حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي ومعها بقيه الفصائل تريد الرد
على عمليه الاقتراب ولكن السؤال اين هو
متى هذا ما ستحدده الساعه
لك احمد يعني متى نتوقع الرد على هذا على
الهجوم والغارات الاسرائيليه الاخيره شكرا
جزيلا لك من غزه الصحفي احمد حرب
مشاهدينا ننتقل مباشره الى موسكو حيث هناك
اجتماع رباعي بين قاده سوريا تركيا ايران
وروسيا لنستمع
استعدادي من العمل المشترك على هذا المسار
ونتمنى يتم التوصل الى نتائج في ذلك ان
روسيا تهدد باي
عقوبات احاديه الجانب
والذي يمكن ان تزعزع الاقتصاد
وتسبب
التمييز بين المواطنين
وكذلك تعيق ايصال المساعدات الى
المحتاجين اليها وخاصه على ضوء الزلزال
الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا ومن الواضح تماما
ان حتى هذه الكارثه لم تجعل الولايات
واحده واوروبا او تضغط عليهما الانسانيا
اللي رفع العقوبات عن سوريا فان الخطه
الانسانيه للامم المتحده لهذا العام فيما
يخص
سوريا قد تم تمويله فقط بثمانيه بالمئه
وهناك نداءات
من قبل الولايات المتحده
للمساعده ولكن في بعض الاماكن السوريه
الداعمه قامت الدول الدعم الانفصال بد
وتمويل مشاريع الامم المتحده بشكل مئه
بالمئه
[موسيقى]
ممثلي
الحكومه السوريه
لا يدعون الى
فعاليات الدوليه
والتي القائمه هذه الفعاليات القائمه على
الحفاظ على المخيمات لاجئين في سوريا
خارجها بالنسبه لنا كدول ضامنه لسوريا
لابد من العمل على اعاده كل اللاجئين
والنازحين الى منازلهم وهذا يعتبر مبدا
اساسي لنا كل مبدا من من هذه المبادئ يفتح
امامنا مجالات عده للعمل وسوف يتم تسجيلها
في خارطه الطريق
وذلك ايجاد كل الاجراءات والمعايير لوضع
الخطط الزمنيه لتنفيذ هذه المبادئ وانا
خارج الطريق يجب ان
تعكس مواقف كل الاطراف وخاصه سوريا وتركيا
بما في ذلك
اعاده
سيطره سوريا على كافه الاراضي سوريا وكذلك
ضمان الامن
بموافقه من تركيا لاجراء او
تحديد 950 كيلو متر من الحدود الامنه
اضافه الى ذلك
لابد كذلك من
توقف عن اجراءات التي يمكن ان تضر بامن
ادول اخرى في العام الماضي قامت سوريا
وتركيا بمثل هذه الاجراءات ونتمنى انه سوف
يتم ايقافها كذلك
نناقش عمليه اعاده فتح
الطرق المواصلات واللوجستيه واجراء او
اقامه التعاون الاقتصادي دون ايه حواجز
ومعوقات اتمنى للجانب التركي
انتخابات ناجحه
واستغل الفرصه هنا بان
نؤكد بان هذه الانتخابات ستكون
الفاتحه وشفافه وتعبر عن
اراده الشعب التركي ونحن نرى
الدور الكبير
والشعبيه الواسعه التي تمتعت فيها تركيا
خلال السنوات الاخيره القادمه
واليوم نرى انه
في هذا العام سوف تتحسن او في هذه الفتره
سنحسن العلاقات المشاركه بين
اذا مشاهدينا كنا نتابع معكم الاجتماع
الرباعي مباشره على الهواء بين وزراء
الدفاع الروسي السوري التركي والايراني
لمحاوله تطبيع العلاقات بين سوريا وتركيا
بواسطه موسكو و طهران طبعا
هنا في هذا الاجتماع سيتم بحث الحلقه
السياسي وانسحاب القوات العسكريه من سوريا
وتوفير عوده امنه للاجئين السوريين الى
بلدهم وقبل الاجتماع الرباعي الذي تابعناه
مباشره الان مشاهدينا قال وزير الدفاع
التركي خلوصي اكار قال انه تم التوصل الى
اتفاق لانشاء مركز تنسيق بين تركيا وروسيا
وايران وسوريا بشان القضايا الامنيه في
سوريا وقال وزير الدفاع التركي ان بلاده
لم تعد قادره على الصمود امام التدفق
الجديد اللاجئين السوريين مضيفا ان انقره
لا تعتبر نفسها غازيه في سوريا وهو ما تم
التاكيد عليه في اجتماع الخامس والعشرين
من ابريل
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع
مع التدهور الامني في السودان تتفشى ظاهره
النهب والسرقه فكيف يحمي المدنيون
ممتلكاتهم نتابع
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد الى السودان حيث يدخل
الصراع يومه الخامس والعشرين على وقع
استمرار المعارك فقد افاد شيود شهود عيان
في الخرطوم بوقوع ضربات وغارات جويه مكثفه
في وسط المدينه منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
وتجدد الاشتباكات بين الطرفين وسط تصاعد
في اعمال النهب والسرقه وقالت قوات الدعم
السريع ان القصر الرئاسي اصيب بضربه قويه
خلال الغارات وافاد مراسل العربيه بتنفيذ
الجيش السوداني طلعات جويه مكثفه شرقي ام
درمان وسط سماع دوي لاسلحه ثقيله
من ام درمان ينضم الينا الصحفي مقداد حسن
اهلا بك معنا مقداد اذا ضربات جويه غارات
مكثفه على العاصمه السودانيه ولكن انت تطل
علينا من اندرمان لنتحدث عن الوضع هناك
بدايه قبل ان ننتقل الى الخرطوم ونتحدث
عنها تفضل
نعم مدينه ام درمان عاده ما تكون اهدا من
بقيه المدن باعتبار ان المواقع او
المعسكرات التي تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع
كان الجيش السوداني قد استهدفها في الايام
الاولى لكن قوات الدعم السريع تنتشر في
مناطق ربما هي يعني
تكون فيها الكثافه السكانيه عاليه جدا
لذلك لا تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات بصوره
مباشره وانما مناوشات هنا وهناك واحيانا
سلاح المهندسين يعني يطلق قذائف تستهدف
مواقع تمركزات الدعم السريع في مناطق
مختلفه من ام درمان وكذلك ايضا جنوب ام
درمان عاده ما تشهد بعض الاشتباكات وغربي
ام درمان باعتبار ان الجيش يقول انها يمكن
ان تدخل تعزيزات عسكريه لقوات الدعم
السريع فهو يستهدفها عن طريق الطيران اما
مدينه الخرطوم هذا الصباح ومدينه بحري حي
الشباك تحديدا وج مدينه بحري كانت شهدت
اشتباكات عنيفه جدا منذ الصباح الباكر
وحتى هذه اللحظه نحن نشاهد الان اعمده
الدخان من مدينه بحري وهي تقع شرقي مدينه
ام درمان وكذلك قبل قليل شهدنا غارات جويه
مباشره
لمواطن تمركز قوات الدعم السريع وهناك
انباعا استخدام قوات الجيش السوداني
للمدفعيه والقوات البريه على الارض
باعتبار انها
ان مدينه بحري تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريع بصوره اكبر وهي المدينه التي كانت
شهدت عن اشتباكات عنيفه جدا اما وسط
الخرطوم فهو منذ الصباح الباكر ايضا شهد
اشتباكات عنيفه وسماع لذوي انفجار بحسب
الذين تحدثنا اليهم وهم يشاهدون تلك
الانفجارات هذا الصباح بدا عنيف جدا وهذا
باستمراره ربما يصاحبه استمرار لازمات
انسانيه وتجدد العمليات السلب والنهب في
مناطق مختلفه من العاصمه الخرطوم ومن
مدينه ام درمان ومناطق متفرقه جدا وتزايد
للوضع الصحي الكارثي الذي ربما يعني ينهار
في اي لحظه بحسب بيانات وزاره الصحه وكذلك
بحسب بيانات النقابه الاطباء وبالتالي
فاننا مع استمرار هذه المواجهات لاسبوعها
الرابع واليوم الخامس والعشرين فانها تنذر
كارثه انسانيه ربما تكون هي الاسوا لان
انقطاع الصراع الحيويه يعني ورغم التطورات
الميدانيه على الارض كان في الخرطوم او ام
درمان او اي المناطق التي الاشتباكات الا
ان المحادثات والمفاوضات تجري في جده في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ونتمنى ان تاتي
اكلها شكرا جزيلا لك من ام درمان الصحفي
مقداد حسن
ومع ترد الوضع الامني في السودان اشار
شهود العيان الى ان المدنيين نضطروا في
عديد احياء العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم الى
تشكيل دوريات حراسه لتامين منازلهم
وممتلكاتهم في ظل استفحال ظاهره الصوت
والنهب نتيجه التدهور الامني
تدخل الحرب في السودان اسبوعها الرابعه
لتحدث انعكاسات متعدده على المواطنين في
كثير من انحاء الخرطوم حيث تعرضت الكثير
من الاسواق والمحال التجاريه والمنازل
للسرقه الجراء فلت الامن ما دفع المواطنين
الى البحث عن حلول لتامين احيائهم
وممتلكاتهم بانفسهم بيحصل
سرقه ونهب
فهنا الحين ما شاء الله رايتنا حله ما شاء
الله ما قصروا يعني ارتكازات ما شاء الله
على مستوى عالي فاغلبيه الناس البيونه من
بره ويحاولوا على سنهم يسرقوا الدكاكين
فالناصر ما شاء الله تصدت لهم ما في دكان
واحد في جريف غريب من الحاره الاولى لحد
الحاره الثانيه سرك
منطقه الجريف غرب احدى المناطق ذات
الكثافه السكانيه العاليه تجاورها محلات
تجاريه واسواق عديده تعرضت للمحاوله سرقه
ونهب من قبل النصوص الذين استغلوا غياب
الشرطه والامن فتصدى لهم المواطنون الشرطه
ما موجوده صراحه والله الشرطه ما موجوده
لكن اولادنا قدروا يعني
الناس الكبار انه يعملوا المنطقه من كل
التفلات الامنيه
من السودان الى باكستان والتي تشهد
اجراءات امنيه مكثفه حيث يمثل اليوم رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان للمحاكمه وقد
اعلنت الشرطه الباكستانيه ان خان لن ينقل
للمثول امام المحكمه بل ستعقد جلسه
المحاكمه في مكان احتجازه في اسلام اباد
رئيس الوزراء احتجز بالامس اثناء مثوله
للمحاكمه في قضايا فسد
اعتقال خان مشاهدينا اثر حاله من الفوضى
في البلاد وتظاهرات مندده حيث افادت افادت
تقارير في مقتل شخص واحد على الاقل في
اشتباكات بين المحتجين وقوات الجيش في
كويتا عاصمه
فيما اصيب العشرات بجروح في اعمال عنف في
كراتشي بشاور لاهور حيث استخدمت الشرطه
الغاز المسيل للدموع لتفريق المتظاهرين من
انصار عمران خان
عمران خان يذوق من نفس الكاس التي طالما
اتهم خصومه بها الامن الباكستاني يعتقل
رئيس الوزراء السابق على خلفيه قضيه فساد
يحقق فيها مكتب المحاسبه الوطني عمران
خانز طبق اعتقاله بتسجيل المصور دعا فيه
انصاره للتظاهر من اجل نيل حقوقهم
اعلم انه سيتم اعتقالي في قضيه ملفقه دون
مراعاه للقانون والحقوق الاساسيه طيله عمل
السياسي كان كفاح سلميا وهذه الحكومه
المستورده والفاسده تريد مني القبول بها
اريد منكم جميعا الخروج من اجل نيل الحريه
الحقيقيه فالحريه لا تمنح وانما تكتسب
بالجد والجهد
الحكومه الباكستانيه جددت اتهامها عمران
خان بالفساد والعمل على اثاره الفوضى في
البلاد
تم احتقال عمران خان وفق القانون بتهمه
اختلاس اموال من حق الدوله قدرها 190
مليون جنيه استرليني والاستحواذ على مئات
فنانات الاراضي بطريقه غير قانونيه انه
يعمل وفق اجنده خارجيه لزعزعه استقرار
البلاد ويشن حمله منظمه للنيل من مؤسسات
الدوله
اعتقال عمران خانيه بعد يوم من بيان للجيش
الباكستاني يحذره فيه من اطلاق اتهامات
غير مسؤوله في اشاره الى اتهامات وجهها
لضابط بالتامر لقتله
انصار رئيس الوزراء السابق نظموا تجمعات
احتجاجيه في عدد من المدن تخللت بعضها
اعمال شغب واقتحام مقرات للجيش وحذروا
الحكومه من المساس بعمران خان فيما قررت
السلطات حظر التجمهور في مدن كبرى واستدعت
تعزيزات من قوات الامن
ويواجه رئيس الوزراء السابق لائحه طويله
من القضايا تتعلق باتهامات بالفساد
والارهاب والاخلال بالامن يعتبرها هو
وانصاره مسيسه وواهيه
في ظل الجدل القضائي والسياسي حول القضايا
المرفوعه ضد رئيس وزراء السابق عمران خان
واعتبار انصاره ان المساس به خط احمر يحذر
مراقبنا من خروج الاوضاع عن السيطره ودخول
البلاد نفقه ازمه جديده في ظل ما تعانيه
من اوضاع امنيه واقتصاديه صعبه عبد الرحمن
زيني العربيه اسلام اباد
ببرع محامي رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق وصف اعتقال عمران خان بانه عمليات
اختطاف وليس اعتقال
اعتقال عمران خان بمثابه اختطاف وليس
اعتقال الامر الثاني ان طريقه اعتقاله تدل
على عدم وجود دستور في باكستان حاليا
وهناك نوع غير معلن من الاحكام العرفيه
المدنيه ونوع من حالات الطوارئ حاليا في
باكستان
[موسيقى]
معنى من اسلام اباد مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن المزيني اهلا بك معنا عبد الرحمن
اذا اضطرابات وتظاهرات وعنف بعد اعتقال
عمران خان واستعدادات امنيه لاي تظاهرات
اثناء محاكمته بدايه هل بدات المحاكمه متى
ستبدا وكيف هي الاستعدادات الامنيه عبد
الرحمن
نعم بالفعل فاطمه بدات محكمه تعنى بقضايا
الفساد جلسه النظر في القضيه المرفوعه ضد
عمران خان بتهمه الفساد والاستحواذ على
اموال واراضي تابعه للدوله بطريقه غير
قانونيه رفعها مكتب المحاسبه الوطني في
بدايه الجلسه طلب محامي الادعاء تمديد
اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان 14
يوما على ذمه التحقيق في القضيه اما موكل
عمران خان فقد اشتكى من ان السلطات حاله
دون السماح لقاده حزب الانصاف بزعامه
عمران خان والفريق القانوني بالجلوس لاخذ
كافي مع موكله على خلفيه هذه القضيه
واعتبر انه ليس من صلاحيات مكتب المحاسبه
الوطني اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان على هذا السياق قدم
بزعامه عمران خان التماسا امام المحكمه
العليا الدستوريه هنا في السنابات يعتبر
مذكره اعتقاله غير قانونيه وغير قضائيه
وغير
شرعيه وطالب بالافراج عنه المحاكمه تجري
وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده السلطات نشرت نحو
1500 عنصر من عناصر الشرطه حول محيط ومقر
المجمع مجمع الشرطه هنا في العاصمه تم
اعتبار البيت الضيافه الذي يجلس فيه عمران
خان سجنا فرعيا تجري فيه عمليه الاعتقال
وتجري في المحاكمه لامران خان بتهمه
الفساد من المتوقع ايضا ان يشهد هذا المقر
او هذا السجن الفرعي ايضا جلسه محاكمه
اخرى
لهيئه محاكمه جنائيه بتهمه الفساد ايضا
على قضيه ما يعرف قضيه الهدايا والتي يتهم
فيها عمران خان بانه
على هدايا مقدمه للدوله بطريقه غير
قانونيه الاوضاع الميدانيه بدات هناك بعض
البؤر الاحتجاجيه في عدد من المدن
الباكستانيه بعد ساعات من الهدوء النسبي
التي اعقبت الاحتجاجات يوم امس هناك حاله
من الكرو والفرع في عدد من المناطق
الاسيمه في بيشاور هناك بعض التجمعات
الصغيره هنا في السماد يقوم بها
المتظاهرون بالقاء الحجاره على الشرطه
وتقوم الشرطه بالتصدي لهم الشرطه قوات
مكافحه الشغب ومكافحه الارهاب ايضا اود
الاشاره هنا الى انها اعتقلت امين عام حزب
الانصاب بزعامه عمران خان اسد عمر على
خلفيه بلاغات قدمت ضده تحت بنود
مكافحه الارهاب بسبب اعمال الشهر التي
رافقت احتجاجات يوم امس
شكرا لكم من اسلام اباد مراسله العربيه
عبد الرحمن المزيني على كل هذه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع
مساء فرنسيه بريطانيه لادراج فاجنر
الروسيه على قوائم الارهاب
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل تساعد في الضفه الغربيه وتتاهب
على حدود غزه ومصر تحذر الفصائل من غارات
جديده
غارات عنيفه للجيش السوداني وسط الخرطوم
وسماع دوي انفجارات واشتباكات شرق ام
درمان
وسط احتجاجات انصاره مثول عمران خان
للمحاكمه في مكان احتجازه والشرطه
الباكستانيه تتاهب
بين الاجتماع التركي السوري في موسكو
انقره تكشف عن اتفاق لانشاء مركز تنسيق
امني في سوريا
احييكم من جديد اعربت الخارجيه الامريكيه
مشاهدينا عن استنكار واشنطن لهجوم مدينه
جربه في جنوب تونس والذي اسفر عن سقوط عدد
من القتلى والجرحى مشيده او مشيده بالتحرك
السريع لقوات الامن التونسيه وقد اعلنت
وزاره الداخليه التونسيه ان احد عناصر
الحرس التابع للمركز البحري للحرس الوطني
في جزيره جربه اقدم على قتل زميله
باستعمال سلاحه الفردي والاستيلاء على
الذخيره ثم حاول الوصول الى محيط معبد
الغريبه اليهودي وعمد الى اطلاق النار
بصفه عشوائيه على الوحدات الامنيه
المتمركزه في المكان والتي تصدت له
ومناعته من الوصول الى المعبد واردته
قتيلا اوضحت الداخليه مشاهدينا ان
العمليات اسفرت عن مقتل رجل امن واصابه
خمسه باصابات متفاوته الخطوره كما قتل
اثنان من الزوار تونسي وفرنسي فيما اصيب
اربعه اخرون بجروح متفاوته تم نقلهم الى
المستشفى لتلقي العلاج واكدت الداخليه
التونسيه انها فتحت تحقيقا في الحدث لكشف
ملابساته ومعرفه دوافعه
نشر الجيش الاوكراني مقطعا مصورا لقواته
المدفعيه وهي تطلق وابلا من القذائف
باتجاه ذا خمود في دونيتك حيث تجري معارك
عنيفه ضد القوات الروسيه وخاصه في الاحياء
الغربيه وياتي ذلك بينما تقول اوكرانيا
انها تستعد لاطلاق هجوم مضاد لاستعاده
السيطره على المناطق التي تنتشر فيها
القوات الروسيه
ونبقى في الشرق الاوكراني حيث اعلنت وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه عن اليوم عن اليوم
الثلاثاء عن مقتل الصحفي ارمان سولدان
البالغ من العمر 32 عاما في هجوم صاروخي
اثناء مرافقته لجنود اوكرانيين وقالت
الاباء الفرنسيه ان اربعه صحفيين اخرين من
الوكاله كانوا برفقه سولدان وقت الهجوم
ولكنهم لم يصابوا باذى حيث ارتفع عدد
الصحافيين والمساعدين والسائقين الذين
قتلوا اثناء تغطيتهم للحرب في اوكرانيا
الى احد عشر على الاقل وذلك وفق منظمه
مراسلون بلا حدود ولجنه حمايه الصحفيين
الرئيس الاوكراني فولدمير زيلينسكي رحب
بمبادره تصنيف مجموعات فاجنر الروسيه
كمجموعه او منظمه ارهابيه قائلا هذا ما
يتعين على العالم اجمع تبنيه حيث ذكرت
صحيفه
بريطانيا ستصنف او بريطانيا ستصنف بعد
نركب منظمه ارهابيه رسميا لزياده الضغط
على روسيا كما تبنت الجمعيه الوطنيه
الفرنسيه بالاجماع تبنت قرارا يدعو الى
ادراج فاجنر الروسيه المتهمة بارتكاب
تجاوزات في اوكرانيا وافريقيا الى قائمه
الارهاب الارهاب او المنظمات الارهابيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي
الى سوريا حيث افادت وكاله الانباء
السوريه بانفجار سياره في حي بيرزا في
دمشق واكد مصدر في الشرطه السوريه للوكاله
اكد ان السياره كانت مركونه بالقرب من
مركز الشرطه وقدم انفجارها الى اصابه ضابط
واربع اخرين من افراد الشرطه
يشكل الناخبون الاكراد مشاهدينا نسبه لا
باس بها من عدد الناخبين في تركيا ولهم
دور مهم في الانتخابات ويمثلهم عدد من
الاحزاب ابرزهم واكبرهم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي المعارض لاردوغان والذي استقطب
بدوره حزب الدعوه الحره هذهبار وهو حزب
محافظ صغير يدعمه الاكراد المحافظون
بالتالي تحاول كل الاطراف جذب النسبه
الاكبر من الناخبين الكرد
[موسيقى]
رغم عملهما معا في مكتب بسيط للعقارات بحي
اسانيورت في اسطنبول الا ان ايدن ونوري
ليس على قلب رجل واحد فيما يخص الانتخابات
التركيه القادمه
كلاهما من اكراد تركيا لكن توجهاتهم
السياسيه التي كانت متوافقه فيما مضى
اختلفت في هذه الانتخابات
في سنوات حكمه الاولى كان الحزب الحاكم
جيدا على كافه الاصعده كثير من الاكراد
كانوا يصوتون لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه
لكن في الاونه الاخيره ولا سيما بعد
التدهور الاقتصادي اصبحت مقتنعا بضروره
التغيير لذلك لن اصوت لحزب العداله
والتنميه بل لكمال كالجدار اوغلو بين
رئيس اردوغان انا راضا عن سياساته تجاه
الاكراد واحبه شخصيا لذلك سامنحه صوتي من
جديد
تقدر نسبه الاكراد في تركيا بخمسه عشر في
المئه من عدد السكان واعتاد حزب العداله
والتنميه ان يكون الحزب الثاني كسبا
للاصوات في المناطق ذات الغالبيه الكرديه
خلف حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي الذي
يملك القاعده الانتخابيه الاكبر في اوساط
الاكراد لكن صديقا الذي مارسته الحكومه ضد
الحزب الكردي وسعيها لاغلاقه دفع الكثير
من الاكراد الى اعاده النظر بموقفهم
السياسي من الحزب الحاكم في البلاد
تحسبا من قرار الاغلاق قرر حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي خوض الانتخابات باسم حزب
اليسار الاخضر واسست تحالفا للاحزاب
اليساريه وهو تحالف العمل والحريه
التحالف الجديد قرر عدم اختيار مرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه بل قرر دعم مرشح
المعارضه كمال كلجدار اوكلو ضد اردوغان
كما ذكرتم يبلغ عدد الاكراد في تركيا ما
بين 12 الى 15 مليون مواطن الحزب الذي
يعتبر ذاته ممثلا للاكراد في تركيا حصل في
الانتخابات الاخيره على خمسه ملايين صوت
وهذا يعني ان ليس جميع الناخبين الاكراد
يصوتون وفق معيار الهويه العرقيه بل هناك
هويه الدين وكذلك دوافع اقتصاديه وغيرها
من المعايير التي تحدد توجه الناخب التركي
في عمليه التصويت في مقابل دعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لمرشح المعارضه استطاع تحالف
الشعب وهو الائتلاف الحاكم جذب حزب الدعوه
الحره والمعروف باسم حزب هدى بار الى
تحالفه ويستقطب هدى بار المحافظين الاكراد
ويعتبر من الاحزاب الاسلاميه المتشدده
لكنه لا يحظى بشعبيه حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي رغم ان مرشح المعارضه كمالك
الجدار اوغلو انتزع دعما من حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لكن كتله القوميين في معسكر
المعارضه ترفض هذا الدعم لانها تراه حزبا
مؤيدا لحزب العمال الكردستاني في المقابل
نال انضمام حزب هدى بار لتحالف الشعب
استياء بسبب تهم تلاحق الحزب بارتكاب
اعمال ارهابيه هي معادله معقده تعكس
اختلاط المصالح والتحالفات في انتخابات
ليست كسابقاتها زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
من الانتخابات التركيه الى الانتخابات في
موريتانيا نددت مشاهدينا احزاب الموالاه
داعمه للرئيس الموريتاني بتصريحات
لمسؤولين حكوميين وقيادات من حسب الانصاف
الحاكم وصفتها بغير المبرره والتي جاءت
على خلفيه احتضان هذه الاحزاب لمنشقينا عن
الحزب الحاكم
الاتحاد من اجل الديمقراطيه والتقدم
المشارك في الحكومه وثاني اكبر احزاب
الموالاه تمثيلا في البرلمان لا يخفي
ابتعاضه من تصريح للوزير الاول اعتبر حزب
الانصاف الحاكم شركه الاتحاد في الحكومه
والموالاه واجهه النظام السياسيه الوحيده
في الاتحاد والتقدم مستقبل هذه التصريحات
او هذه التهديدات بمستوى عالي من
الاستغراب والاستهجان والانها ليست مقبوله
وليست متفهمه من حزب نتقاسم ونحن وهو
اغلبيه داعمه لفخامه رئيس الجمهوريه
احزاب المعارضه انتقدت ما وصفتها بالحمله
التي يقودها اعضاء الحكومه لصالح الحزب
الحاكم واعتبر التصريحات المسؤولين
الحكوميين دليلا على سعي النظام للهيمنه
المطلقه على المشهد السياسي ورفضه للشراكه
حتى مع حلفائه فالمعارضه لا يمكن ان
يخالف بعضها بعض وان تشترك في معارك
سياسيه وكذلك الاغلبيه فكان كل منهم منسجم
في اطاره وكلهم يبحث عن تقويه الطرف الاخر
اما ان تكون الصراع الداخليه فهذه اول مره
وما يحدث الان بين الاغلبيه والحزب الحاكم
فهو مساله غريبه
يحجم قاده حزب الانصاف عن رفض او تبني
التصريحات التي اثارت استياء احزاب
المولات
وتجنبنا ابراهيم رئيس الحزب الرد على سؤال
للعربيه عما اذا كانت التصريحات المثيره
تمثل موقف الحزب الرسمي
ونوابه
واعطيت الحزب تنم
والنافقون الرسميون باسمه يوضحون موقف
الحزب
اخرى
وانا ادعوكم الى تتبعي ما يقول الاخرون
وكانكم منشغلون انشغالا تاما بما اقوله
انا وحث قيادات الحزب او رئيس الحزب ناطق
الرسمي يسعى الحزب الحاكم خلال هذه
الانتخابات الى الحفاظ على اغلبيه مريحه
في البرلمان بينما تسعى احزاب الاغلبيه
الى تعزيز تمثيلها البرلماني مدعومه
بالوزن السياسي لبعض المغاضبين من حزب
الانصاف ترشحوا تحت الوانها ابراهيم مصطفى
العربيه نواكشوط الى البيت الابيض
مشاهدينا حيث اعلن انتهاء سريان الزاميه
التطعيم ضد فيروس كورونا للمسافرين الى
الولايات المتحده وموظفي الدوله وذلك
اعتبارا من الحادي عشر من مايو الجاري
وجاء في بيان لرئاسه الامريكيه ان
الولايات المتحده ستنهي متطلبات التلقيح
ضد فيروس كورونا للموظفين الفيدراليين
والمقاولين الفيد راليين والمسافرين
الدوليين جوا في نهايه الحادي عشر من مايو
وهو اليوم الذي تنتهي فيه حاله الطوارئ
الصحيه العامه في البلاد
ومع كل تصعيد بين اسرائيل والفصائل
الفلسطينيه في غزه تبرز صور مؤثره لاطفال
سقطوا ضحايا لغارات وصواريخ لا ترحم اكثر
من 2000 طفل قتلوا في غزه خلال جولات
التصعيد في السنوات الاخيره فيما ترك
الاخرون بمشاكل نفسيه كبيره حيث افادت
منظمات امميه ان 80% من الاطفال غزه
يعانون من صعوبات نفسيه وهم بحاجه ماسه
للمساعده
عذرا
وصلت الطفله ميرال الى المستشفى تريد
اباها ولم تعلم انها صارت يتيمه ابوها
وامها قتل في الهجوم الاسرائيلي
الطفله بحاجه لتدخل نفسي عاجل هي وثمانون
في المئه من اطفال غزه وفق منظمه انقذوا
الاطفال الدوليه ست حروب سابقه على غزه
تركت اثار نفسيه مدمره على اطفالها الحروب
المستمره على قطاع غزه لابد ان تترك اثارا
انيه واثار بعيده المدى بالنسبه للاثار
الانيه وخلال الساعات والايام القادمه قد
يرى الاهالي مجموعه من الاعراض تظهر على
ابنائهم الخوف الشديد نوبات من الهلع عدم
قدره على النوم او حتى تقيؤ غير مفهوم
السبب او حتى اشكال اخرى من الاضطرابات في
الجهاز الهضمي اذا ما اعتبرت ميرال من
الناجين فان علي وميار وهاجر لم ينجو
قتلته الصواريخ الاسرائيليه وهم في فراشهم
وامسوا وقود حرب لا ترحم
اكثر من 2000 طفل قتلوا خلال السنوات
العشرين الاخيره
ذنبهم الوحيد انهم ولدوا في غزه
قبل الختام مشاهدينا نشير الى هذا العاجل
امامكم على الشاشه حيث يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان هناك خليه للجهاد خليه
الجهاد المستهدفه في غزه كانت تستعد
لاطلاق صاروخ اذا الجيش الاسرائيلي استهدف
خليه للجهاد كانت تستعد لاطلاق صواريخ اما
الان الى العناوين
اسرائيل تصعد في الضفه الغربيه وتتاهب على
حدود غزه ومصر تحذر الفصائل من غارات
جديده
قاره عنيفه للجيش السوداني وسط الخرطوم
وسماع عدوي انفجارات واشتباكات شرق ام
درمان
وسط احتجاجات انصاره مثور عمران خان
للمحاكمه والشرطه الباكستانيه تتاهب
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات